combination of Canadian wildfires and
Northerly winds is blanketing a hundred
million Americans in Smoke in Cincinnati
some Brave the outdoors on foot in cars
and on the water beneath a Skyline
shrouded in Haze the picture was the
same in Indianapolis on Michigan's
Mackinac Bridge in Milwaukee where smoke
fills the skies trapped by warm summer
temperatures and in Chicago where this
week surely Ann Manson singer of the
band garbage ended her performance early
with this apology
[Music]
shorts are set slightly short
and I just um I feel so bad about it I
just want everyone to know that
[Applause]
Here Local leaders are urging residents
to wear masks or stay indoors especially
if they have respiratory problems last
night I really was coughing a lot when I
now I'm a little more used to it but I'm
a bit horse
as you can maybe hear at times this week
Chicago's air quality was recorded as
the worst of any major city in the world
an iconic landscape with no defined
outline this is the clearest Chicago
skyline has been for three days on the
air quality index it's been over 200 for
the past 24 hours Health officials say
at just 150 staying out here all day is
the equivalent of smoking seven
cigarettes
there are now about 500 wildfires
erupting in flame across parts of Canada
[Music]
half of them burning out of control one
the size of Rhode Island
and the Fire season has just begun John
hendron Al Jazeera Chicago
heat related illnesses are on the